so let me start with a sincere
congratulations uh the movie's awesome
um you guys promoted the film I I Sophia
I don't know if you went to Brazil I
don't remember but you both went to
Comic-Con and Justice traveled to Brazil
you've been promoting the movie pretty
good
um so I guess uh how happy are you that
the movie is awesome really yes
that makes me think that you didn't know
if it was awesome
you you read a script and you're like oh
this is fantastic I really hope it it
perfect you know it's good it's good it
stays this way and um and then but you
know the thing with films is that it
constantly changes you know the script
is one film practically you shooting in
is another film that you editing it
makes it entirely different film and I
think it ended up being
um it could be it was a little bit
different than the than the than the
script I guess it's gonna have to be but
it's they still had the right elements
in it and they still kept this
um you know the humor and the I think we
are a chemistry added to it and
everything and I think and in the end we
we made a really good movie yes I agree
and I and I actually like it me too
that's good that is good yeah one of the
things about the film is that it's
really funny the action is well staged
and you actually care about the
characters
um what are you most excited for
audiences to see in the film
um well with fans there's a lot of
Easter eggs that we've planted for them
and I think they're gonna be
happy
um John Jonathan also infused the story
with the spirit of the game by making it
uh funny like and by funny I mean like
it doesn't take itself too seriously and
when you play the game which I've only
played once but when you play the game
it is kind of just like farting around
and trying to make your friends laugh
you know and uh I feel like there's lots
of that
in the film
good job good good answer thanks you
want to add anything Oh Me Oh
he said it pretty well
let's then jump into real quick too I
believe the dragon's name is chunky I
could be wrong about this
um
Denver Tron oh Denver shot I think just
to be clear I think it was on the either
John or Jonathan tweeted chunky with the
poster you know what I mean like one of
those I was hilarious anything yes so
that's how I could get it's a nickname
it's like uh sub yeah it's a pet name
for a thumper charge
Trump
just real quick what was your reaction
though when you finally saw the finished
VFX of that Dragon because it looks
fantastic
um it's incredible I mean we I kind of
knew it was go it was going to look like
that because a lot of we had a lot of
practical effects on set and you could
see the like character design in the
Practical effects there's a scene where
we have a Dragonborn uh beggar who's
like a oh yeah poor Dragonborn creature
and the animatronics on this creature
were insane it's sweat they made a head
with like all this like facial
recognition stuff and there was a guy in
the back also puppeteerious and it was
and there's a guy in it puppeteria it
was my I love I love uh uh physical uh
uh uh practical effects and yes I also
just like because like kind of like a
labyrinth type of thing I also was a big
fan of this is more of like puppet stuff
but I I love uh dark crystals so same
people kind of remind me of like some of
the
um but you could tell from that
character design what the CDI was going
to look like right on that note I need
to stop I'm just gonna say I think I'm
gonna see you both at a screening
tonight
[Music]